we get cookies every Wednesday according
to everyone out there like Ronnie spends
20 minutes every Wednesday at least
delivering cookies well it's a whole
thing the cookies are delivered you know
there's like boxes yeah and he comes
bringing them in and then he opens the
boxes spread them all out and then he
starts making plates and letting certain
people in so they can select here's the
whole thing so Jason confronted him on
they've done the wrap-up show and I
agree with Jason I'm sorry and who put
you in charge of this person all the
food in the morning is moving over there
[ __ ] open the box Ronnie
you come in you take it upon yourself to
load up plates and plates of food [ __ ]
why what is he doing why is he handing
out these cupcakes
I don't know how this evolved because
you know the cupcakes have been coming
for years and and now they are Ronnie's
cupcakes
Ronnie sits in Scotts to do the morning
stretch the shoulder break are you going
in nope
all right Ronnie won't come in here
takeaways Rick's plugs no more no more
plugs ever that's it don't defy me let's
tell them how here he is okay I almost
tried to take away your rigs plugs take
it thank you thank you all right no more
Rick's scare me man I can't deal with
your [ __ ] anymore because you're
like like a general [ __ ] Custer over
there well let me ask you something you
know what let me do whatever you do
whatever you want all right
cupcakes stick them up their ass I don't
give a [ __ ] okay trying to be a nice
[ __ ] guy leave the pot I'm not
touching those boxes [ __ ] Jason could
shove them up his ass you can have them
all okay come you all right how come
when a guy listen it's idiotic what's
going on with the cupcake explain it to
me let me hear an irrational adult
you're 65 [ __ ] years old that's 60 62
okay all you're in your sixties it's not
like it at all
you're not in your sixties go ahead are
you or you're not go ahead what else all
right
if the receptionist out front is
listening Ronnie's forty yeah I listen
to me what's going on now the way I
envision so you the way I always
envisioned your job okay got some knives
that it a draw start sharpening stabbed
in my back were you so grumpy yesterday
if you think that fat bastard out there
put me right over the top yesterday over
[ __ ] black and white cookies well I
guess the stupid [ __ ] all right
let me understand something and he's out
there cackling now and I hear him I can
hear them through the soundproof [ __ ]
walls okay all right listen to me what
you don't think clearly go out there and
spend the [ __ ] hour out there you'll
know why he's in everybody's goddamn
business I like them good that's my boy
that's good I used to be your boy I
guess I'm a piece of [ __ ] to you now oh
that's what this is you treat me like
garbage man hey you never stick up me
one [ __ ] time if I was right or wrong
I wouldn't matter to you I'm always
wrong [ __ ] don't even [ __ ] look
at me you what does everyone hate you
know I don't think so I have friends
people I like here like can't seem to
like me they like you I don't think I
think we just learned I'm as my walk
over here I guess it's not about me
anymore though I think this is really
about you I got nothing to do with him
[ __ ] well talk to me then come back here
Ronnie I'm gonna take away the Rick's
plugs I'm gonna take it all away yeah
he's out of control take away his beard
die all I did yesterday was ask who put
them in charge of the cookies but that's
it and you know what the answer is no
one that put him in charge of it sorry
about it well what happened did you
here's what happened if you don't get
what you want by like 604 it's gone
because Ronnie collects it all and
disperses it so I wanted to do that
so I went over there for plates at have
Hanson shock
all right Ronnie let's settle this out I
can get this done it's not [ __ ] funny
first of all I never said I was in
charge of the cookies Jason no you won't
see what do you guys guy setting the
[ __ ] up that's all I did
Ron let's see would you like me would
you like I can listen to you you don't
let me see if you wanted me to explain
it all right go ahead so let me explain
it okay okay
plain and simple all right those boxes
come in they're sealed in with tape and
the whole thing all right
so lots of mornings you come used to
come in they'd just be sitting in nobody
to open them I said okay I open them why
why not
are you eating him no all right so why
are you hoping him I don't hire you to
beat a cookie maybe once okay that's me
never ate a cupcake never touch one ate
a cookie no problem with you opening it
for yourself okay go ahead but I want
you to stand there in your suit and be
the voice of reason you had to be a
cupcake cookie delivery boy okay
there's several gay people that don't
yeah like Jason that's right yeah well
so why is he crying about him for cuz
he's hungry he's fat giving away his
favorite son right in other words once
you start collecting cookies and
deciding who gets what I need the site
away from people who are here in the
morning hello you are deciding no how
many people do you collect keys for dude
yep hold on a second if you take a
cookie for Rosa's ape and Tracy ere is
the two responses in boxes of cupcakes
comes twelve O'Clock this 500 cupcakes
still left that nobody touches them okay
so you're saying nobody eats them
hardly anybody eats okay so why you come
so why waste them
wait the cookies let me explain the
cookies right all right okay are you
involved in it there's a box of cookies
there right black and white cookies
maybe there's two dozen right is that
what's in there I don't know oh come on
come on you made a big deal at me
yesterday you could they're not there
when they're not there I know what a
commercial for cross
right so I took three cookies out of
there yesterday and I put them on a
plate all I know is yeah yeah black and
white cookies are gone by by 10 after
6:00 if you don't get one right you're
doling them out in advance what if I ate
three cookies but you're not running
four plates over the thing I'll and a
cookie know anything he says I'm at his
[ __ ] door so can right now okay leave
Ronnie why are you threatening me with
leaving if you want to leave this time
please I can listen to him he's not my
[ __ ] boss I don't have to listen
anything he says but the guy is saying
he can't get the cookie I just add um
Weston listen to me yeah you asked me a
question look at me
you gave me a whole [ __ ] lecture look
at me I'm gonna make this easy balls
give me a [ __ ] lecture I said don't
take all the cookies before people here
get a chance to get them my big cookies
jason-3 at a two and a half dozen all
right okay all right listen to me plates
of food you got a security job right
you're supposed to be the voice of
reason you should stand there like a
lamppost like a lamppost observing
everything not inserting yourself into
situations you ever see I don't want to
ever hear Buckingham Palace yeah where
is it I don't know
you don't even know where Buckingham
Palace and look in Switzerland I don't
know okay
there's guards is it stand outside a
buckin brightly the most professional
yeah they won't even smile I won't even
smile in fact you see the uniform is one
of those I'm gonna get you the uniform
no I'm a red jacket the Hat old [ __ ]
ways gonna remind you even have a beard
like no that's what I was trying to do
this morning but I'll break my balls I'm
breaking your balls cuz you get into
trouble out there I'm not gonna miss
your personality is it's too much
everything was not nobody said boo about
everything's fine it's obviously causing
a problem it's causing a problem with
him cuz he doesn't get enough cookies
you don't want to give this up do you
you love yeah I'm not no I don't care I
don't care you still wanna make you know
not touching I'm so how are these people
don't survive you know what they can all
know it's all boys in here no one's
gonna starve to death because you won't
deliver this fine it's fine with me all
right so what are you so you're now not
gonna deliver such a [ __ ] alright good
I'm even touching those boxes good one
if you want a cookie I'm not touching it
I don't even want a cookie I don't want
your cookies and who is your hero
Buckingham Palace right and I don't have
any heroes no bucking Tony Stewart's my
hero alright okay alright go out there
and be a professional now Eddie going
we're done alright alright okay did you
learn anything no you didn't know I just
learned that
go ahead lunch something yeah I learned
what did you learn don't put in my head
my own head that's you need to go out
and process what you learned no all
right no thank you thanks general right
that's right your general is telling you
get with it consider this a pep talk
cookies
you big fat [ __ ] any time you want
outside very angry limo driver over
there
slash security guy slash your
meals-on-wheels guy did you throw
something somebody yeah is the matter
with you what's going on what is going
on stop it let's get your boy your
fair-haired boy in here put them here
Ronnie it's not funny no I know it's not
funny right okay I'll talk to you off
two years
no I you're not just talking to me see
cuz that's this is the [ __ ] problem
I'm gonna talk to you off do you know
you're gonna talk to both of us off you
tell me what to do and I'm gonna tell
you I'm gonna talk to you off the air
about it not and we'll have a discussion
we're not talking about it well you're
gonna have to talk to someone well
you're gonna talk to me no I'm not yes
you are I get up every when I'm sitting
out there minding my own business and
all I hear
and his big fat mouth is [ __ ] coming out
of his mouth about me What did he say
but I don't know here's my name and
that's all I need to hear you can't
throw something at somebody at this
place
it's not right dude don't put it all on
me what did he say about you I have no
clue so then why would you throw
something at him do you hear how I
believe lay it off today what I said lay
off did he say my name out of your mouth
and all like you're not - stop saying it
Scots to do minding my own business all
right Ronnie
I don't care if you hear your name I
don't care you can't throw something at
somebody what what is his deal don't
worry about it why is that you said what
is the instigator probably come to me
about know I've been all I've been is
nice to this frigging guy Ronnie now let
me tell you something What did he say
about you you don't even know just keep
my I said don't keep my name out of your
mouth he's allowed to say your name I'm
sorry he is you can't work in this
environment if you can't stand hearing
your name you're out of control I don't
know what's going on around here
everybody's losing it what did you do I
don't know anything wrong Ronnie came
back red face don't talk about me don't
mention my name but the screen I'm
saying my dad this whole time out of
control so I stuck my tongue out I don't
get I thought he was that'd been silly
he charged me grabbed me and threw a
real garbage can at me and uh I'm not
happy about that I stopped being funny
now that's unacceptable
alright I'm like the big just now when
he was saying no no no you gotta talk to
him - that was just like a child talking
to his father saying no no no my older
brother or my younger brother you gotta
stop blaming me for everything yeah I'm
not following Ronnie around trying I was
sitting on my desk I was trying to stay
out of his way he can't he came back
there I don't know I don't know how I'll
deal with it off to here cuz I got no I
got so much [ __ ] aggravation my life
now I got this sorry thank you yeah
thanks guys
sorry alright i'll daddy you'll take
care of it